foreign the qubit was a measurement fit
for royalty taken from the elbow to the
tip of the middle finger or equivalent
to about Seven Palms this unit inspired
one of the earliest standard measures
the Royal cubit which might have been
used to build the Great Pyramids
some researchers have proposed that
measurements using the body were merely
Stepping Stones to standardized units
but new research is complicating this
story
I had a very strong suspicion that it's
not something of the past because of
many of my hobbies for instance I'm a
very typical fan I do a fair bit of
cross-country skiing and of course even
today when you go to a Finnish store and
buy cross-country skis you will measure
them against your height I do a fair bit
of sea kayaking and kayaking
traditionally still uphold many of these
body basins measure
to see how widespread these measurements
are the researchers searched for
mentions of body-based units in 186
cultures we basically found body-based
units in every inhabited cultural region
in the world so measures of length were
definitely the most common you'd find
the qubit fathom hand span and so on it
was interesting to see how many
different variations of these very
common units exist so for instance some
cultures might measure the qubit from
the elbow to the fist or to the tip of
the fingers
quite often they were used surprisingly
similarly so for instance the unit
phallum was used specifically to measure
slack items such as cloth or ropes or
fishing nets they always carry your body
with you so it makes sense to use that
when nothing else is available you will
find some units of volume that appear
across different cultures such as the
familiar handful I'm full pinch we also
collected units of measure that are
related to bodily activity some very
commonly occurring ones were for
instance a Day's Journey the nicobaris
used young coconut drinks as a measure
of distance if you are seafaring you
want to have this very particular unit
of hydration as essentially in a measure
they also looked at whether body-based
measurements persisted after the
introduction of standardized units
body-based chance of measure pretty much
in every cultural region persist in
centuries or Millennia after the first
emergence of Standards often they are
used in a way that today we perhaps call
ergonomics so when you use your own body
as a base for reference you'll actually
design the tool to be specifically
custom tailored for your own personal
use I suppose much of this tradition was
also lost in in the industrial
revolution when mass production kicked
in not only do body-based units make
better fitting tools and clothes but
they often reflect local knowledge these
units of measure typically do have a
strong sense of place so they're tied to
specific practical needs of specific
cultures when some cultures for instance
where they live in highly mountainous
terrain makes a lot of sense to measure
distance as risks required but we only
kind of touch the surface of this
question of you know how how and whether
what a base measurement persisted after
the emergence of statins so I'm sure
there's lots of detail there to be
uncovered on how perhaps our local
cultures around the world perceived the
imposition or introduction of standards
and whether or not they soil is
purposeful to adapters
[Music]